世間が過ぎて物を壊したくなりますこんにちははじめ社長と
フラニーですあの子の講演でよく動画とるんですけどこの今実は急に禁止なんですよ
多分な人が多いがボールとか飛んでく危ないからだかご覧ください
jr ところで野球サッカーシャボン玉
防具だけでサボんだものサーモンのは選挙で
ん結局台で飛んで行くと危ないところなんですよそれで競技研修なってればセミ不正な
とって越生もハードボールって危ないストリアただブラインで禁止なんですよ今日は
そんな中域へ氏の声で遊べそうなものを準備しました
大こちら知ってこれスーパーバブル不思議な強いたバブルボールを待っており救助です
q じゃねこれ家れるんですよさ盆玉みたいなニコは見てこの少年をこのように悔いは
ねってか裏三でますっでも握れ仕入れる市ふぐセルシオ中継ぎ何でも出来るみたいな
ボール現在脱走やけど
破けねシャボン玉でペリア美形あぼん大っっっ
まあ動画のタイトル的にいうとまあチョンチョンっ
アース我ら住む家僕ん
パパッ
まぁちょっと話はもっと言うと絶対に破けない巨大なシャボン玉です4
ちょっとこれで今日はするにをボコす行こうと思うんだけどコスパも4
まず単三電池4本必要です
33買ってくるんじゃない餅みたい
待ってドライバーないんだけど持っ
ねーわっです
ドライバーって書いておいて欲しかったまじでヤバイよこれがぶっ壊すか向こう
今吸ってみんじゃないかだって彼はいらないんじゃないブックを使ってきます
wh
俺やばい本当に壊れないんですか
いや
男の子はそれが音が相応からから新田瞬そうですね
腰ナンボですからあああ
あああああ麦どうせから通院チョコしてはここをパカってくればいいんですよとずと
なると
そうそうだな世界で一番手っ取り早い方法は
5ドアみたいな人に止まっても居れば
一番て釣り場へ方法は
[音楽]
はっはっはキザ
ああああああああ
[音楽]
ブーブーコレッリます
em ん
はっはっは te
eme
em
[音楽]
なんかすげーは決定も全然はれねー
んちょっとナッター
あっはバーンねどんだけぷっするぞとしも潰れないしぶん殴っても全然大丈夫です
でほんとすごいなんかはれに絶対はれないってのは結構本当っぽいですねこれ乗っても
割れないんだっけ
もう1回乗ってみますもっとられたら俺溺れ読む
あー声やーのもう慣れてるのでてる古い吸引トラコレと
me
ざーいった待って撃っ
スフ
[音楽]
やばいです
me
ございます5位
さーせん
んだ甘いてが1人増えてませんはい
ん
ああああああっ
俺の高いではありがとね一つです
はいはいどこれマジで壊れないですよねことあーこれショットたらもっと膨らません
じゃねっと思ったんでちょっともうちょい膨らまして大きくしたかと思います
よこれこれぱやばいん
それでえええええええすごいはぐらいページがばシャボン玉
からだってっ
[音楽]
えっ恋
そりゃああ
西ページガーが
です
[音楽]
いいえ
さあそれ
須沢いただいたらよ
def
eme
これはえっ
[音楽]
goo
頭痛ファー
[音楽]
me
teal
ana あああっ